hablamos de economía en directo América
Daniela hablando bienvenida Muchas
gracias María Clara y empezamos con
malas noticias porque el panorama
económico no pinta bien para América
Latina por qué Por lo menos María Clara
eso es lo que piensa la comisión
económica para América Latina y el
Caribe o la cepal que redujo levemente
su proyección de crecimiento del pib
regional para 2023 en diciembre la tenía
en 1,3% y ahora en 1,2% y la región el
año pasado había crecido mucho más que
eso y dice que el escenario es complejo
Porque a las salsas en las tasas de
interés se le están agregando las
turbulencias financieras además se
espera un descenso en los precios de los
commodities y las regiones gran
productora la buena noticia es que se
estima que la inflación se va a
desacelerar Bueno pero esto es un
promedio regional cuéntenos A qué países
les irá mejor y a cuál es peor claro
desde luego cada país tiene su propia
situación entre los que tendrían una
mejor recuperación este año en América
Latina estaría en Venezuela pa y
República Dominicana mientras que chile
Haití y Argentina serían los únicos que
presentarían crecimiento negativo otros
como Colombia o Brasil están en la parte
baja de esta tabla con expectativas de
crecer apenas 1% y una aclaración
también hay países que crecen mucho pero
es porque el año anterior habían bajado
mucho y es un efecto rebote y usted en
los países a los que les va a ir bien
mencionó a República Dominicana y a
Panamá y es que precisamente
Centroamérica y el Caribe son dos de las
subregiones latinoamericanas a las que
les irá mejor según las proyecciones
pues su previsión es del 3,1% y del 9,1%
respectivamente para América Latina y
para Centroamérica y para el Caribe
parte de ese resultado se debe a que se
espera un mejor crecimiento en Estados
Unidos que es el principal socio
comercial y la primera fuente de remesas
de estos países pero el verdadero
flagelo allí son los bajos salarios
según la organización Internacional del
trabajo el ingreso mínimo mensual en los
países de Centroamérica oscila entre
equivalente a 213 dólares y 614 dólares
dependiendo de la nación siendo
Nicaragua el que menos percibe y Costa
Rica el de los salarios son más altos
como estamos observando en el gráfico y
le propongo que ahora hablemos de Chile
de donde determinó el congreso de la
Industria del Cobre hablando de
commodities pues este país es el mayor
productor mundial de cobre y acogió a
cientos de actores de la industria esta
semana cuya principal conclusión es que
el apetito mundial por el cobre que es
el conductor de Electricidad por
excelencia y se necesita como insumo
para la mayoría de los dispositivos
electrónicos va a superar la oferta
durante la próxima década si bien Se
espera que la oferta aumente en 26% en
el mundo hasta más de 38 millones de
toneladas anuales en 2035 Es probable
que se quede 1,7% por debajo de la
demanda esto según la asociación
Internacional del cobre el presidente de
la estatal chilena codelco habló de su
panorama en particular
tuve una caída importante de producción
el año pasado 2022 en relación al 21
el 23 nuestra producción va a volver a
caer y esperamos poder recuperar los
niveles de un millón 700 mil toneladas
incluyendo nuestras
filiales
en un plazo digamos de cinco años
Daniela aquí hemos hablado bastante de
las sanciones económicas contra Rusia
pero lo nuevo ahora es que a pesar de
estas hay más multimillonarios en ese
país lo está diciendo la revista Forbes
que en 2021 había registrado 88
ciudadanos rusos cuya fortuna pasaba los
mil millones de dólares hoy son 110 es
decir hubo un aumento del 25%. el ruso
más rico es andrey Mel michenko fundador
de la compañía química internacional
eurochem el principal fabricante de
fertilizantes que tiene una fortuna
estimada además de 25 mil millones de
dólares
del zar del níquel también de un
empresario siderúrgico y del fundador de
la empresa de gas novatec además el
fundador de Telegram del total de esta
lista casi la mitad ha sido objeto de
sanciones por parte de occidentes Y
bueno pues sigue siendo ricos usted
menciona que el ruso más rico tiene 25
mil millones de dólares comparemoslo con
la cifra del día bueno pues la cifra del
día son de 173 mil en 600 millones de
dólares esto es si mal no me fallan los
cálculos pero hay unas seis o siete
veces más de lo que tiene este
multimillonario ruso pues esta es la
fortuna estimada por Forbes también de
elon musk quien ya no es el hombre más
rico del mundo según esa publicación
tanto esa publicación como bloomberg
Index que El Magnate fue superado por
Bernard horno Quién es el dueño del
grupo Louis Vuitton más que no ha tenido
su mejor semana como lo hemos venido
diciendo por un lado su empresa de autos
de lujo tesla se redujo drásticamente
sus ganancias porque bajo precios y los
inversionistas lo castigaron con un
desplome del 10% de la acción solamente
hoy A eso se le suma todo este fracaso
de su misión con spacex cuya nave
starship explotó en el aire Poco después
de despegar con rumbo al espacio no
pagaría un tiquete con lo que cuesta
para irme al espacio en una nave de
estas ni siquiera si tienen 173 mil
millones de dólares Pues él es el dueño
o sea el que se va a beneficiar Entonces
no creo que él tampoco se vaya por allá
Gracias Daniela por toda la información
económica y a ustedes Les propongo que
continúen viendo el debate aquí en
directo América